faire une chaîne massy bonjour
et bienvenue dans la matinale de rtl
france on le disait à viktor orban qui
se rend donc aujourd'hui à moscou
justement pour obtenir une augmentation
des volumes des gaz de la russie on le
disait la hongrie touchés par une forte
inflation ces dernières semaines un
objectif c'est un partenariat qui est
important pour budapest cette rencontre
en russie compte tenu de la flambée des
prix en europe de l'énergie oui alors
c'est pas une c'est pas quelque chose de
nouveau et les gens qui s'intéressent un
peu à la russie ou à la hongrie au 2è la
politique étrangère savent que ça fait
longtemps que victor robert mais en fait
au delà victor valdes la hongrie
entretient depuis longtemps des
relations pragmatiques et cordiales avec
la russie puisque depuis changement de
régime en début des 90
la anglais à une situation de dépendance
énergétique vis-à-vis de la russie que
ce soit pour le gaz le pétrole ou même
l'uranium puisque l'anglais est aussi un
pays qui a calé centrales nucléaires
comme vous l'avez évoqué
donc c'est même les gouvernements
hongrois avant victor ban qui était
résolument atlantiste entretenait des
rapports tout à fait pragmatique et
cordiaux avec la russie pour la hongrie
c'est une nécessité c'est l'intérêt
national de l' anglais donc en réalité
c'est c'est c'est simplement encore une
fois une politique pragmatique de viktor
orban qui évidemment profite de cette de
cette relation cordiale qui s'est
construite sur des années de coopération
en bonne intelligence pour
aussi être comme un grain de sable dans
une dans la machinerie occidentale
dont la hongrie fait donc partir de
l'otan et de l'union européenne
et dans la crise ukrainienne
particulièrement ce qui est intéressant
c'est que l'anglais est membre de l'otan
et que ça n'empêche pas victor ban qui
est le dirigeant d'un petit pays de
l'otan qui est clairement pas un des
acteurs majeurs de l'otan mais d'être un
grain de sable dans cette machinerie et
ils profitent de cette situation pour
faire valoir les intérêts en bois alors
justement dans un contexte on le disait
d'augmentation des prix notamment des
prix des produits de première nécessité
comme la farine le blé ou le sucre et à
partir d'aujourd'hui est bien viktor
orban a décidé de que ces denrées de
base vont être plafonner les prix
s'envolaient significativement ces
derniers mois
oui alors il ya il ya clairement une
hausse des prix qui est qui et qui est
très nette je crois que en décembre on a
sur les produits d'alimentation à une
une augmentation une moyenne
d'augmentation qui était de 9,4 pour
cent l'ag de la l'inflation de base en
décembre était de 6.4 donc cesser c'est
un plus haut historique depuis depuis
plus de 20 ans
dont la langue est évidemment n'est pas
le seul pays touché par ce phénomène
c'est un phénomène qui touche
globalement tout le tout l'occident
l'union européenne aussi des états unis
alors les l'usure caprice victor bahn ne
sont pas des à proprement parler des
mesures pour contrer l'inflation
évidemment ce sont des mesures
temporaires
choc et qui sont aussi il faut bien le
dire électoralistes en début avril le 3
avril il y aura des élections générales
en gris donc victoire ban
évidemment se représente avec son parti
de fides et
dans ce contexte la bloquer les prix de
quelques produits et élémentaire on peut
les nommer ainsi
est donc une mesure qui est aussi à mon
sens dans l'optique des élections c'est
ce que dénonce également l'opposition
puisqu'il lui victor hoban dit vouloir
protéger les familles en bloquant ses
prix l'opposition effectivement lui
reproche une manoeuvre électoraliste
c'est un sacré coup de pouce qui
s'inscrit dans une logique en effet de
protection c'est vrai c'est que encore
une fois c'est une mesure qui ne qui
n'empêche pas l'inflation c'est pas une
mesure économique à proprement parler
pour pour bloquer ou empêcher
l'inflation draper mais c'est vrai que
pour les plus début dit c'est quand même
une vraie aide
la même façon qu'il a bloqué au mois de
novembre il a ils ont mis un moratoire
sur le gouvernement hongrois mais un
moratoire sur la hausse du prix de
l'essence donc depuis depuis début
décembre le prix de l'essence et du
diesel en gris est bloquée et fixe
un prix qu'ils ont calculé pour être
abordable on va dire pour le hongrois
moyens donc il ya quand même même si
hors ban est un économiquement et un
libéral mais il est souvent qualifié de
libéral non orthodoxes c'est à dire que
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui ne se ne
s'accroche pas bec et ongles à une
doctrine libérale absolue mais il est
très pragmatique encore une fois il est
capable d'utiliser les outils de l'état
pour arriver à des aspects en politique
et trouver un équilibre
vous parliez de ces élections du 3 avril
ces législatives qu'elle est là la
popularité aujourd'hui de viktor orban
en hongrie
écoutez elle est en réalité les
à-peu-près
un touché c'est à dire que le pays est
très polarisée il ya si vous voulez des
gens qui adulent victor haubané des gens
qui le haïssent c'est ses traits marqués
en général personne n'est vraiment
indifférent et est en réalité son
sur sa base d'électeurs et est stable
très solide et étant donné la jeunesse
attend pas le temps de rentrer dans les
détails mais on a publié un article
intéressant sur la situation de
l'opposition unie en vue des élections
étant donné les bévues et les
difficultés qu'ils éprouvent
l'opposition
je ne m'en fais pas trop pour la
réélection de viktor orban
donc en réalité en anglais il a il a
surtout ce qui est important c'est qu'il
a une base d'électeurs qui est qui est
stable et très forte et par lui des
indécis ils arrivent en général à
conquérir des voix sur la ligne
d'arrivée de toute façon mais là la
marge semble assez nette entre lui et
l'opposition unie merci beaucoup faire
une chute massive pour votre éclairage
ce matin je le rappelle vous êtes
rédacteur en chef du village grade poste